how to avoid the digital ID Mark if the
mark of the beast or Mark if the Beast I
think he's asking I think if I'm not
mistaken Joe Biden announced recently
that he passed a bill or some
legislation for a social credit score
did you guys see that
I didn't see that but I know they've
been pushing it I worked for a big four
company for the last few years recently
into that contract and that they were
internally like they were really pushing
that uh the the like the digital Bank
currency or whatever too they're really
um here let me just see if I can find
some more Joe Biden passes
social private
okay news
let's try that
tax season by the little now that might
have been a announcement
somebody see that's the thing like I you
know you can't really tell when you see
stuff on social media if it's if it's
real or if it's somebody just doctored
something because it's just there's so
much inaccuracy but you know to the
point that it's coming which
I think it is coming you know like how
do you avoid that
have you guys put any thought into that
yeah
uh Bitcoin cash silver
no there's no way to avoid it entirely
there's just ways of minimizing your
presence and learning to live with it
they're willing to minimize your first
note
yeah unless you want to have an uh a
lifestyle that's totally unplugged
totally disconnected from the world you
know like living in a cabin somewhere in
the mountain without a Christian in your
house
you're not going to be able to avoid it
I mean if you buy stuff with their
currency which will be some sort of
Central Bank digital currency let's be
honest you know if you buy it with their
currency it's programmable money that's
that's that's trackable it's not cash
it's programmable money they will know
what you buy at the grocery store they
will know what you buy at the drugstore
they will know how often you fill up
your gas tank and with how much and with
what grade of fuel they'll have a
photograph of you doing it as well so
you'd have to think of ways of opting
out in that space and you truthfully you
know like Drago said I don't you
truthfully completely can I think you're
probably going to have some ability to
be somewhat a non in that you know
scenario whether or not you've got the
option to use cash or other but they can
Ruby Ridge you at any point we saw that
in the nine in the 90s oh it's like that
Randy Weber story northern Idaho where I
think he it was something like an
undercover FBI agent or something tried
to purchase a or it gave him like a
ridiculous amount of cash to like soft a
shotgun he's like okay yeah I'll use
some cash sold off the shotgun then they
sent the feds in killed his son killed
his wife and and then eventually they
were able to get him out and I think he
was acquitted of all charges but um and
then they did the whole narrative like
oh he's like a white National or
something like no he was like a former
Green Beret he just wanted to live in
the in the cabin
um it was the anniversary of Waco not
too long ago so I I grew up down the
road from there uh so I remember that
when I was a kid um well we left Texas
when I was like eight years old and I
grew up in Washington state but I
remember that so so when the documentary
comes up they always mention like the
Ruby Ridge thing and after that I'm a
nerd I'm like well let me watch the
interview of like the daughter and stuff
this poor girl is probably like eight
nine ten years old and traumatized her
all because and it was it was a sting
operation but they kind of set him up
too like we'll see a lot more of that
like yo you didn't ride a bike to work
or your car doesn't get enough fuel
economy and then send the feds you know
arm to the teeth to take care of you
yeah so I mean look the scenario that
I've painted before I'll just restate it
this this is a very real
thing that's going to happen for us and
I'm going to say probably within the
next decade would be entirely reasonable
um you're gonna go to the grocery store
and because they've been tracking your
purchases and they're concerned about
the climate
you've bought too much red meat you're
at the checkout counter and you want to
buy your steaks and the cashier says
sorry sir you've exceeded your uh limit
for red meat this month here's a bag of
crickets or bugs instead for a new
source of protein and then you might
want to get into your car and drive
somewhere but because it's an electric
car and it's connected to the government
like I was talking about this in a video
months ago the government is instituting
and they did this very quietly they
didn't make a big Public Announcement
nobody really talked about it but
they've instituted that new vehicles
within a certain time frame need to need
to be programmable and controlled by the
government so if they want to shut it
down and the argument that they're using
is we don't want to endanger the public
and have another O.J Simpson scenario
where we have a highway where you can't
stop the vehicle when you've got police
cruisers chasing this guy we just want
to be able to be like oh he's in this
vehicle with his license plate turn it
off and then it stops driving right I
bought a car in Texas one time where the
dealership disabled that they're going
through the list of options like oh
OnStar yeah obviously they don't want
the government tracking they'll be the
black market to sort of hack that but at
the end of the day you're going to end
up in a scenario where if you've driven
too much and you get in your electric
car and you want to go and drive
somewhere it won't work and you'll get
like a notice on the screen it says
you've exceeded your carbon credits
please make or please accept this
penalty payment or this tax payment of
whatever through your cbdc account
immediately to the government to drive
your vehicle this is where we're going
to go so if you want to opt out of that
you need to have a gas powered car or be
able to uh hack into the car to sort of
you know disable things like that get
energy from solar or wind you know for
example off their grid and produce
yourself like you need to get off their
system and create your own system but
there's not going to be a way to
completely stay off it I mean if you're
going to be living in society plugged
into Road systems schools culture
government uh Public Services like fire
policing and all that stuff you're part
of the system you're a cog in the wheel
there's no question about it I'm
assuming they're nowhere to track you
there will be something where like high
net income people or earners will be
able to buy credits or trade credits for
example like I spend less than 30 days a
year in the US for tax purposes so like
like I'd have a surplus of carbon
credits tax credits Pro to animal Source
protein credits like could someone like
me potentially or hypothetically in the
future sell those to someone that like
hey you know what I'm a billionaire in
San Francisco I don't really care about
this hey Jaren you're you're never here
you know I'll buy your credits because I
think they used to do that at the
Industrial Level with carbon credits
back in the day didn't they well you
know you're going to see these social
credits things happening man and you
know the final version we don't know
exactly what it's going to look like but
I bet you can come back to this video in
10 years and be like Rich was
pretty much right I really hope you guys
enjoyed that clip if you want to watch
the full length podcast you can find
that over here that clips from if you're
new to the channel make sure you hit
subscribe over here and pin down below
in the top comment you'll find a bunch
of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out